welcome to playing with science brought
to you by startled and stitcher
Chuck nice hi I'm Gary O'Reilly and this
is a show where we actually meld
together science and those who love
science and sports and those who love
sports and what could be better it's
like you got sports in my science its
science in my spunk
mmm it's like a Reese's Cup of
deliciousness with sports and science if
you love science we've got that if you
love sports we have that we have Neil
deGrasse Tyson who actually interviews
some of the most notable players in
sports like Kareem abdul-jabbar's
and Tom strut Lance Armstrong hopes solo
private pension Ryan Fitzpatrick
yeah that's to name a few and in
addition to that we talked to the people
behind the technology of sports CEOs of
companies that make the games that you
love so much more interesting to watch
and we also have scientists like Chuck
Luke come on and break down the physics
of the actual sports plays themselves in
other words we're geeks and jokes
collide absolutely what could be better
could be better who wins in that
exchange it one way to find out just
remember when you play with fire you get
burned when you play with science you
get learned
take a listen to this clip from playing
with science where Gary and I talked
about the Immaculate reception today we
are talking about the most famous play
in the history of American football so
true a play that still divides the
opinions of sports fans almost half a
century later a play that is shrouded in
more mysteries and conspiracy theories
than a presidential election yet we can
solve and explain those mysteries by
using science yes we can the Immaculate
reception was a moment of desperation in
the final seconds of a postseason game
that became the turning point in one NFL
franchises history whilst turning the
other into a battle against the rest of
the world that is still going on so
let's get some numbers straight shall we
7 & 6 the score rate is up by one point
it is the fourth quarter it's a fourth
and down there are 26 seconds left there
are men on the sidelines built like
mountains who are too scared to watch
this is the point of adrenaline this is
the point of fear it's the moment you
live for it is an AFC playoff game and
then it all happens with that in mind
when you said when you said everything
had to be in the right place at the
right time for for this play that even
happened yeah that brings us to a clip
where you know our own Neil deGrasse
Tyson actually sat down with the
quarterback of the New York Jets Ryan
Fitzpatrick and you know asked him about
this particular play I think we have
that clip we've been trying to pull
quarterbacks on their knowledge or
memory of a reaction to the famous
Immaculate reception do you do you guys
talk do you go in a back room and talk
about that is it it was it just a bit of
inspiration how does it land on you and
your and your soul as an athlete I
thought I mean it's amazing play and I
wish that I could get some of that look
you know because that you know
it was a Terry Bradshaw yeah Terry
Bradshaw - I'm Franco Harris yeah off of
somebody's shoulder off the big head and
then it catches it basically on the
ground and now runs for people and I
mean there's so many amazing things that
had to happen exactly right for that
play to work so if you candidly
recognized the role of luck in that yes
yes I don't know it was much of anything
else
yes hence Immaculate reception rather
than skillful research well I think
that's great we've got a current NFL
player with enough about him to respect
the history even though he kind of sits
on you know are really lucky so and
speaking of luck this is something I
just like to ask every scientist do you
believe in luck no I have yet to meet a
scientist who says I believe in luck why
not man tell me I mean I know why most
science has answered this question but I
want to hear yours because I just find
it fascinating that I have yet to meet a
scientist when you say do you believe in
luck I've not met one scientist who said
of course who doesn't I mean we're
governed by the laws of the universe
we're constrained by the laws of physics
and I mean luck is simply what the word
we use for a low probability occurrence
I mean if you win the lottery you say
you got lucky well that's the word
you're referring to hitting a one and a
fifty million shot or whatever the
probability is okay somebody's going to
hit it if you play all the numbers so I
you know it's not a it's just luck is
just the word that we're using in the
layman's sense to describe things that
are very low probability and occurrence
awesome I like it all right so no such
thing as luck there is such a thing as a
break we are going to take a first one
right two questions firstly who was the
head coach of the raiders on the day of
the Immaculate reception and secondly
how many Super Bowls did the Pittsburgh
Steelers win on the back of
the Immaculate reception during only
during the decade of the seventies right
we are gonna leave you a moment to think
about that and we're good luck thinking
about that yet and there no such thing
so when we come back we will have a
rather special guest by the name of dr.
Neil deGrasse Tyson and we will be
discussing some more science will of
course have Professor Eric golf and Jim
Brennan who's with us in the studio so
do not go away so what do you think
everybody here our talk is pretty
excited and we can't wait for you to
listen then you can find playing with
science wherever you listen to podcasts
on stitcher radio iTunes podcast google
play music SoundCloud and tune in new
shows premiere every Wednesday night at
7 p.m. Eastern subscribe now and don't
miss a single science filled episode oh
we just not just went out the park baby